hello everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a for kids and others
let's see so we have a few questions
saved up from previous times but i want
to say that that
in general
you're welcome to ask me
anything about sort of how stuff works
scientifically technologically if i know
um
and uh about perhaps things that you
might have heard about in school or
elsewhere and it's like
what is this how does it actually work
what what is this really all about
um
those are those are good things which
will perhaps
get us going in interesting directions i
mean for me
uh what i like about these uh
sessions
is
by asking me all kinds of questions that
uh i've never never thought about before
this gives me an opportunity to think
them through and uh i end up
understanding them deeper than i than i
did before so i really appreciate that
um
all right okay we got two questions that
just came in all right
first question from crunchy
is there really such a thing as infinity
or is it just a concept
that's an interesting question
okay what is infinity
well there are
different
let's talk about it in terms of like
mathematical infinity let's talk about
it in terms of numbers
we can say
we just count one two three four five
etc and we just keep going forever
that's one version of infinity another
thing we could say is
let's be doing arithmetic let's work out
1 over
let's say 1 over
0.1 that's 10. 1 over 0.01 that's 100
etc
1 over 0 what's one over zero
oh it's infinity
that's another kind of
thing that gives us infinity so we can
like count forever we can compute one
over zero
those are two versions of infinity but
we can ask
a
a question like
uh i don't know
if we allow
um
if we are making up combinations of
letters abc let's say we've got abc and
we say what possible orders are there
for that there's bac cba etc there are
six possible orders three factorial
orders for that we say what if we have
an infinite number of letters how many
possible orders are there for that what
if you have any i shouldn't say an
infinite number what if you have any
number of letters how many orders are
there for that again it's an infinite
number of of orders
so they're questions like so first
question is these are ways to sort of
generate infinity these are ways of
saying if you do this mathematical kind
of thing you will get something that we
can talk about as infinity
now you say well what is infinity well
we can say for example in wolfram
language we have a symbol that's just
infinity just the word infinity and if
you say one divided by infinity you'll
get zero so we can just pick up that
thing that we call infinity and we can
do operations on it now it's a little
bit more subtle than that because
actually there are different kinds of
infiniti
there are for example even
one type of issue is
um
when you deal with complex numbers for
example or
let's say let's say we're just looking
at
we have
coordinates in the plane and we say
we're going to figure out we're going to
go an infinite distance away from the
origin well it may matter whether that
infinite distance is along the x-axis
along the y-axis or off at some angle
those are in a sense all different
infinities um so there might be more
information that was needed to sort of
characterize the infinity but
nevertheless you can in a sense just
pick up that symbol infinity and do
things with it and do operations on it
there's an elaborate theory that i think
i talked about once before of
transfinite numbers
um invented about 140 years ago now um
that is a kind of a very nuanced theory
of infinity and all all sorts of
different mathematical ways that you can
get infinity
but so
at one level you can just
sort of pick up infinity and talk about
it symbolically you just have the symbol
that is infinity one over to zero and
and for example here's a question if you
have infinity one over infinity is zero
okay what is infinity minus infinity
probably that's still just infinity but
you can imagine a whole elaborate theory
of sort of nuanced theory of what these
different combinations of infinity
actually are
well so a question is okay you've got
this thing that is infinity is that
is that enough is you know can you
actualize infinity can you you know you
can say i can talk i can reason in terms
of infinity but can i actualize infinity
can i actually make infinity in our
universe
that's an interesting question what does
it mean what is the difference between
merely being able to talk about infinity
and being able to sort of hold all of
infinity in your hand and deal with it
um i think
the one way to think about the
distinction between these things is
there is a notion of a symbolic infinity
that you can get by imagining a
mathematical process where a a um
when okay when you get infinity by just
finding successive integers
that is an infinity
which can be described as a process that
is a very straightforward process to
describe
but another version of infinity would be
some very elaborate complicated
computational process that never
terminates and it's always doing new and
different and interesting things but it
keeps on going forever
that's in a sense a differently
parametrized version of infinity
and i think that that version that that
you could say oh i'm just going to
characterize that as it takes an
infinite time to halt or it it just goes
on for an infinite time but there's more
structure inside that infinity and one
feature of an infinite process is that
there can be an infinite amount of
structure inside an infinite process
and when you say
i've got this thing that is like an
infinite number you're just imagining
that's just one plus one plus one almost
one infinite number of times but an
infinite process could contain all of
this complicated stuff that's going on
so for example in our model of physics
it is quite likely that the history of
the universe is in some sense an
infinite process where we've just got
you know we've gone through 14 billion
years of it
but it is potentially an infinite
process going into the future
and that's something where the
to compress that and just say oh it's an
infinite
is to lose a lot of the structure of
what's happening
so i i think my my answer is
that
you know the the thinness of infinity
there is a sense in which one can
sort of consider infinity as a thing
just a symbol in a symbolic language or
something
but
in a sense that is that is
sort of conflating lots of different
things that one might
that could be packed into infinity if i
say a thing
well the word thing conflates lots of
different kinds of objects which could
all be called things the tricky thing
about infinity
is that
when you say it's an infinite thing
you can pack
an arbitrary amount of detail into that
infinite thing if it's only a finite
thing there are only some in some sense
some set of some limited set of
possibilities that it corresponds to
where is an infinite thing there could
be an arbitrary level of stuff
associated with that thing
that's that's at least some some version
of this
um i think uh
let's see
um
uh a question from jonas here does
infinity have a magnitude
well
usually
i'm not sure what one means here by
magnitude but but um
this whole question
okay i mean uh let me maybe not get into
too many of these details but i would
like to say that there there's a lot of
nuance to the concept of infinity
both trans-finite numbers which are a
construction there are so called
transfinite ordinals which are what you
get by counting successor successor
successor plus one plus one plus one
plus one plus one that's a the thing you
get by infinitely doing the process of
counting up
is the transfinite ordinal usually
called lowercase omega
the um you can then say what is omega to
the power omega or what is omega to the
omega to the omega to the omega infinite
sequence of powers that has a different
name that's called epsilon zero usually
that's another transfinite number and
you can ask questions like is omega to
the omega to the negative omega bigger
than omega plus one answer yes that's a
sort of that that's the fine detail of
infinity those are ordinal numbers
then there's the question
of
um
when if you take
um
if you just say how many numbers are
there that's a cardinal number so the
number of integers is aleph zero
um that's and the number of
real numbers
the number of numbers with with
specified by decimal digits
is usually called lf1
and this big question is two to the lf0
um equal to
uh lf1 that's the thing called the
continuum hypothesis
and that's the thing where there's a
whole discussion about whether one
should consider it to be true it's
something which is independent of the
usual axioms of mathematics the usual
axioms that are used in set theory
and
so
there's there's sort of a whole issue
of what does mathematics look like if
you assume the continuum hypothesis
versus if you assume not the continuum
hypothesis
and one of the things
that is i think quite interesting is you
know there's two different branches of
mathematics one in which
you assume to the l of zero is equal to
alpha one and one in which you assume it
isn't
and
the um
you can say well what are those two
branches of mathematics
is it like just two sets of
mathematicians who think different
things or is one fundamentally true and
the other one fundamentally not true
it is my guess right now
that in some sense mathematics
is
a
well this is getting us into too deeply
into into kind of
foundations of mathematics and meta
mathematics and so on but let me just
say that i have a suspicion
that
if we assume that mathematics is being
done
by in a sense humans with certain
characteristics
then it can quite possibly be the case
that we are effectively by virtue of
those characteristics of us as people
sort of exploring the universe of
possible mathematical truth
we are necessarily led to a particular
conclusion to that hypothesis but anyway
back to infinity so there's counting of
numbers ordinal numbers cardinal numbers
then there's counting of
uh
in a sense
um
that's it's more like counting of
processes
and then you get into these things like
quantification over integers you say for
all integers the following thing is true
then you can say
for all functions that take an integer
and return an integer this is true
or you could say for all
uh
that you can go to these sort of higher
levels of of quantification of saying
for all of this kind of object that is
generated by some some process this is
true and and that leads you to these
these sort of higher levels of infinity
that are more associated with processes
than with again the things with
transparent numbers are also associated
processes but they're very
straightforward processes they're
processes that
um
uh have um
um
that have uh kind of that are very just
take the success of a number take the
success of a number rather than do this
arbitrary kind of computation that you
might do
i mean i would say yeah there's there's
much more to say about that
um
it's uh
okay so jonas is asking is infiniti
really a mathematical object
um well yes
what does it mean to be a mathematical
object
it means
you can
do structured mathematics with that
object
and it is absolutely true
that there are axioms
you know insofar as we think of
mathematics as being based on axioms
that we assume are true like x plus y
equals y plus x there are absolutely
axioms that can be applied to these
various forms of infinity turns out that
x plus y equals y plus x which is
something true of finite numbers is not
true of transfinite numbers so that's
something where there is a mathematical
statement that would be true for all
finite numbers not true for infinite
numbers uh at least not true for
infinite numbers as represented as
transfinite numbers and so yes you can
you can um uh but but yes there's
absolutely a sort of theory of infinity
but one of the things that's tricky is
when we do mathematics we are
essentially implicitly assuming certain
axioms and mathematics like x plus y
equals y plus x and so on those get made
explicit in more formal mathematics
like the piano axioms for arithmetic and
so on when we deal with infinite things
nobody really knows what the right ax
seems to use are and there are different
choices like for example what i
mentioned with the continuum hypothesis
there are different choices of axioms
that might lead you to different
mathematical conclusions
in fact the way that works when one's
dealing with infinite quantities and
transfinite numbers and so on
is um
there are a whole collection of
different axioms one can use that extend
effectively to deal with things like
transparent numbers they're usually
called the large cardinal axioms and
there's just a infinite collection of
possible such actions you could use each
will lead to a set of different
mathematical conclusions so it's no
longer the case when you're dealing with
these infinite quantities that the same
kind of intuitive mathematics
that you know we've kind of used since
the babylonian times will work
instead we have to be more formal and
say this is what we're assuming then
these are the inferences that we make
and these are things which we can we can
conclude and that so when you say but
what's correct you know when we have one
axiom system about infinity we get this
have another axiom system we get that
what's correct
well the answer is we can't say and the
reason we can't say is because we can't
actualize infinity in the universe for
some of these other things where we're
talking about finite numbers and so on
we can imagine actualizing that in terms
of you know we collect have a collection
of stones and we add some number of
stones and so on and we can say in our
actual universe x plus y equals y plus x
but when it comes to infinite numbers
because we can't actualize the infinite
numbers in our universe we can't on the
basis of the physics of our universe
come to a conclusion about that the real
question is can we come to a conclusion
about that on the basis of us
as the entities doing the mathematics
and i think we might be able to come to
such a conclusion we might have the
the result that basically if we are
entities doing mathematics who have for
example bounded computational
capabilities and certain kinds of of of
things that relate to sort of
consciousness and our thread of
experience and so on if we have those
things then it necessarily is the case
that we should consider as reality
certain axiom systems for infinity
um
so
that's um uh that that's that's the
kind of the way that that
works let's see there's a question here
from what's the difference between
counting numbers and counting processes
uh well there isn't a difference between
those counting numbers are just one plus
one plus one plus one plus one the
process of counting
is a nice simple thing that we can sort
of describe in terms of transfinite
numbers
but
when we have
a
let me give you an example
okay
so let's say that our process
is something where instead of taking a
number one and we just add one we have
one we have one we instead we have a
string
a b a a a b b b something like this and
at every step we replace bb by aaa let's
say and we also can replace a b by
something else
okay there are many different string
replacements we can do if we set up the
right string replacement there might be
an infinite sequence of string
replacements we can do
but it can be very complicated to
characterize unlike the case of numbers
where it's just a chain
one two three four in the case of those
string replacements we get what i call a
multi-way system of all these possible
replacements that can happen and that
infinite process
of all these different replacements that
can happen it's a much more elaborate
thing than just
the the chain of counting of numbers and
so it's not something that we can
characterize in the same way by just
using for example the theory of
transfinite numbers it's an interesting
question whether we can this is
what vastly more technical issue whether
we can characterize uh certain families
of multi infinite multi-way graphs these
graphs that represent represent kind of
what gets rewritten as what whether we
can characterize those infinite
multi-way graphs in terms of something
like transfinite numbers whether there
is essentially a calculus
of the structure of those infinite
objects and the answer to that is not
known i mean it's it's known in some
very restricted cases for things called
combinators but it's not in general
known um and my guess is that that there
will not be a finite calculus that can
be given of those kinds of infinities
um
so
uh
let's see
um
crunchy is asking and this is a slightly
more technical question is rule space
finite or infinite uh real space is
infinite um but it's infinite in a very
elaborately built up way
um but that's that's a complicated story
okay
that was an interesting question
all right let's see
um
oh mikhail is asking how is it possible
that the infinitive integers is smaller
than the infinity of floating point
numbers well that's the continuum
hypothesis
um
okay the question here
about um
boy there's a question here from aaron
why can't mules and
zonkeys
reproduce what are limits for different
species of mammals breeding with each
other
uh this is an interesting question i
mean so you know the question of species
is
a
even sort of what constitutes a species
and
how we can in some theoretical sense
predict
when
speciation is going to happen is an
interesting one so you know clearly we
look around and we see different animals
we see different kinds of animals there
are
you know there are all these different
kinds of birds and mammals and beetles
and and all these other kinds of things
and
they
are
here's the interesting thing about them
it is not obvious why
life
breaks into these different species and
why
why there's a certain number of
different species so people believe
there are maybe 10 million species
currently in existence on earth
there are as you go from the big
critters like us mammals
there are many fewer there's thousands
of species of mammals i think um and and
similarly maybe a few thousand birds and
things like that
when you get down to smaller organisms
you get more more kinds of species
and
the this question of why does it break
into these different species interesting
question
and by the way i mean i think there are
like if you look at
standard taxonomic databases databases
where people have said there is a name
for this critter and it is you know homo
sapiens or something you know it's
usually there's a there's usually um the
the so-called
um
uh binomial nomenclature invented by
linnaeus
for species usually has sort of these
these two parts to the name so it's um
you know rattus no vegas or something as
the common rat or i think bufo bufo is
the common toad where it's
being used by the that both both pieces
of the same name but um the
if you look at taxonomic databases i
think there are about one and a half
million
species that appear in those databases
and and you might ask a question how
does a species come to exist not come to
exist as in in the biological evolution
sense but just how does a species get
recorded in the world so you know
there's a certain rate of people finding
new things new creatures you know i
somebody i
uh once knew had found a new species of
lemur in madagascar
you know you can find people go out in
particular the amazon
rainforest
and find the amazon jungle and find
all sorts of new species of beetles and
things like this
and there's a certain um and then what
happens is somebody finds their beetle
what do they do
well they have to get a type specimen
they have to get a particular instance
of the beetle that they go and preserve
and for example you can go
in the natural history museum in london
i think they have a collection of of
type specimens found by charles darwin
that are stored in formaldehyde or
whatever um you know in uh
these all these different kinds of
barnacles and things like this
that were identified as separate species
by charles darwin and so you
you um
uh you get the type specimen you you put
it in a museum somewhere um then you
register the name with the uh
what is it international commission on
biological nomenclature i think and they
have certain rules about what kinds of
names you can you can put in although
people people put in some pretty wild
names
and there was a there was a thing going
for a while where you could like sponsor
a beatle and you could uh sort of uh buy
naming rights to the beatle and things
like this
but any case so that's sort of how
species get identified there's a type
specimen so that's a a particular beetle
that has you know is one particular
beetle
and that beetle has certain dna it has a
certain genetic sequence and that is a
sample genetic sequence for that kind of
beetle but not all beetles of that
species will have the same genetic
sequence just like not all of us humans
will have the same genetic sequence in
fact no two humans except identical
twins will have the same genetic
sequence typically uh each person has of
the six billion base pairs each person
has has some uh many many millions of
differences but from other people and
usually any given person has maybe
around half a million
uh sort of uh things that have never
been recorded before typically and maybe
have never been never occurred before as
those particular changes in the genome
of human so what does it mean to be of
different species it means
not there's a certain sort of zone of
variation within a species where there's
you know let's say six billion base
pairs maybe there's uh i don't know 20
million base pairs that are differing
between different members of a species
but it's still within the species
then you say well let's go to a
different species well now there's more
change in the genome how much more
change
well turns out
that
life on earth is not particularly
innovative at some level it's kind of
outrageous when you look at the
different kind of systems that exist in
us for you know the way that cell
membranes work or the way that cells
generate energy or the way our immune
system works things like this there are
many many of those things that have been
conserved
for a really long time so maybe they the
ancestors that we had in the in the
history of life on earth from a billion
years ago already had their insulin
system and their this system and their
that system they were already existed
there so in a sense those those things
we they were not those are not you know
unique innovations of our genome
and so this question is why do things
break into
species where there is a a big variation
of the genome versus within a species
there's sort of a little variation of
the genome now it doesn't always work
that way for example for viruses
it's uh which have much shorter genomes
like the the the
uh you know the sars2 coronavirus um
that is made this pandemic
it has a 30 000 base pairs 29 000 base
pairs in its uh genome sequence
and there are many variants you know the
delta variant this variant that variant
those variants
have i'm not sure exactly how much the
variation is it's it's some
uh
it'll be
maybe maybe hundreds of base pairs i'm
not sure um
the uh but in any case this notion of
sort of speciation is a little bit
different for viruses there's a there's
a a much there's potentially a much
larger number of of these variations the
other thing that happens is that can
actually be uh you know another thing
that should mention is
okay so
in in higher organisms
species
sort of happen because of reproductive
isolation
that is um you know a
a i don't know a zebra can mate with a
zebra but a zebra cannot mate with an
eagle
just doesn't doesn't work
and so
but with viruses there can be much more
kind of crossover of this one virus and
a very different virus can combine their
genome to make another kind of virus so
this idea of speciation by reproductive
isolation like that doesn't really work
for these very lower organisms so to
speak
now you know why is it
why do things break into species why is
it the case that as you go um through
through biological time why is it the
case that this thing that started off as
just
one type of zebra or something
broke into you know in the fossil record
you might find first there was a sort of
proto-horse
and then the proto-horse broke off this
kind of horse and that kind of horse or
for the for example the history of uh of
primates
and leading to humans for example there
were all these different things the
neanderthals the uh denis sovens the um
uh the the what are they called the homo
florensis the little little uh uh
predecessors that we had these were all
different kind of variations
that all broke off as different species
now of course it's more complicated
because we know
that uh neanderthals mated with with
homo sapiens and that's why you know
there's a certain fraction of our genome
that is a neanderthal genome
and uh i think people from northern
europe tend to have a little bit more of
that than people from other parts of the
world
um but so you know that's a case where
this broke into a separate species isn't
really quite right
um but so usually
what tends to happen is that you know
for
there's okay what will tend to happen is
let's say there's a particular type of i
don't know horse or something and one
horse is living in forests and one horse
is living on
on grassy plains
well
it could be the case
that
the the process of biological evolution
will lead the horse
that lives in the forest to have a
different kind of tooth or something or
a different kind of hoof than the horse
that lives on grassy plains um and what
does it mean that biological evolution
is doing that it means that the the
horse that's on the grassy plain that
has the nice hoof that allows it to
gallop around the plains
is um uh is likely to be more successful
and therefore to have more children and
therefore there are more of that kind of
horse with that kind of hoof whereas the
one that lives in the forest where if
you had that kind of hoof you would trip
up a bunch and you would break your leg
and you wouldn't have have little horse
children so to speak um and so your line
would die out
and so instead what would happen is
those horses that happened to have a
kind of hoof that was well adapted to
walking around in the forest there'd be
more of those and you and you
progressively get more of that so these
different environments will end up with
horses with different hooves let's say
in in one environment versus another and
what was originally oh it's a
general-purpose horse that will work in
both environments steadily there will be
more and more sort of variation to the
point where the horse that's on the
planes will have this kind of hoof the
horses in the forest will have this kind
of roof and these in a sense and then
there comes a point
when
those horses kind of when they don't
mate anymore and exactly why that
happens and whether that's just
you know well that horse doesn't you
know
it's uh doesn't think that other horse
is cute or whatever else
or simply it you know one horse is tiny
another horse is huge if they were to
mate it would be a disaster because the
little horse embryo you know if the if
it was a female horse which was tiny and
a male horse that was absolutely huge
and the and the um uh you know and and
they they mate then there'll be some
giant horse horse fetus that's growing
inside the tiny horse and that would be
totally bad news and the tiny horse
wouldn't even make it um so things like
that can happen where there's sort of
reproductive isolation because it
doesn't uh it doesn't work to have to
have those things mate and that's kind
of the the sort of the general theory of
how
how species break apart
and what can happen
and i don't know the details actually of
why
um
mules for example
end up
being there's probably some very simple
genetic explanation which i should know
and don't for why mules end up not being
able to mate with with um uh with other
mules there may be some very there's
probably a very obvious reason for that
in some of the genetics of what's going
on but this question of of uh sort of
what leads to this sort of isolation of
species it's something to do with the
environment of the species something to
do with the actual morphology of the
organisms of things like you know are
they the wrong size and shape um to be
able to successfully mate and so on but
it's also possible and nobody really
knows i think
the extent to which you know maybe
in some weird case
this one organism will mate with some
other organism that's a little bit
that's quite different somewhat
different from it and in that case they
will successfully produce an offspring
much like what happens with the mixing
of genetics and viruses but with viruses
it works most of the time with larger
organisms it won't work most of the time
but maybe you know it is certainly i
think still within the realm of
possibility that there are incredibly
unlikely events
where two slightly different species end
up mating and producing something which
is genetically completely different and
really starts a completely different
line
as opposed to the more gradual process
of oh there's a small mutation in this
in there there are species there are
organisms that are very similar that are
mating they produce a um
a
genome that's very similar that that
okay so when
when
when uh
uh organisms mate and they
they will their
dna will be combined so for example
if you look at
uh
like if i take my children as examples
right they have a half
half of their genome half of their dna
comes from me
half comes from my wife
and um the um
uh and they they'll have about half a
million or so
places on their genome where there were
mutations that happened that are
uh new mutations that were not didn't
come from either of the parents so to
speak their new inventions in their
genomes but how does it actually work
the the combination of genetic material
from from different parents the answer
is so our our genome our six billion
base pairs are broken into 23
chromosomes which are just stretches of
dna that sort of uh are separated that
curl up separately
and each one is replicated separately as
well but they're just parts of our full
complement of of dna but then what
happens is on every given chromosome
during this replication process there
will be some stretches of dna that come
from one parent some stretches of dna
that come from another parent and
they're these so-called crossovers where
on a given chromosome you'll have a run
of stuff that comes from one parent and
a run of stuff that comes from the other
parent and i think i i looked at this
for my kids i think they're about
five crossovers per chromosome so that
means that there'll be a run of stuff
where they get everything from parent
you know from their father and versus
everything from their mother and and
that gets that sort of their runs of
that through a chromosome and so it's
sort of interesting because
the you know you might think oh that
would mean somebody would get you know
their father's nose and their father's
ears together so to speak because those
are close together on the chromosome the
fact is that our
the the different capabilities of
different features of of organisms are
so mixed up
in the in the in the sequence on
chromosomes that you don't tend to see
those kinds of things that come together
although in principle they might but so
that's that's kind of the way that the
mixing happens is through these these
crossover events where you're getting
from one parent versus the other on on a
single genome and and where those
crossovers happen is kind of random it's
a detail of what happens during the
replication process but that's that's
sort of what leads to that um uh that
difference and and you can kind of
wonder you know what well
that's sort of the origin of of um uh so
within a species those are the kind of
variations that are happening as you go
to different species you have much
bigger variations that presumably
happened through an accumulation of
small mutations although might have
happened through some bizarre giant
crossover event from two rather
different organisms having having uh
successfully produced a progeny
but um i mean this question of of how
many for example this question can you
estimate on the back of an envelope how
many species there should be on the
earth
nobody knows how to do that
there are some laws that say that on an
island of a certain area that tend to be
a certain number of species and as you
change the area of the island they tend
to be more or less species there tend to
be more species as the island gets
bigger um
those those empirical laws
may be
uh not
really
statements about the process of
evolution as statements about you know
how do things get to be on an island at
all you know you have to fly there
because there isn't a you know a land
way to get there or something like this
so uh but but it's a very interesting
question even why there are then
why there are lots of species why
you know why there aren't a trillion
species why there aren't only a thousand
species
people might say well there are lots of
different you know
niches in the world and so therefore
there are more species to handle
different niches but i i suspect that
you know among other things the
existence of different species creates
different niches so for example when
there's different kinds of trees
those
you know if there are different kinds of
trees in a certain area those create the
the sort of the wherewithal to have
different kinds of birds and different
kinds of beetles and so on and so it's a
it's a complicated interwoven network of
of different things and it's i think by
no means self-evident that uh you know
there might be intrinsic niches
associated with the geology of the earth
and the climate of the earth
but then there are niches that are made
by the existence of other organisms and
it's not at all obvious
why
there should be why the the number of
species on the earth is on the in the
millions for example if we found some
other planet that
had been populated by life like like fun
earth and that planet was let's say a
much bigger planet would we find that
there were many more species on a bigger
planet or not
if the earth for example if it was the
case that uh less of the earth was
habitable less of the earth could
support the kind of life that our
chemistry of life supports let's say
more of the earth was was like
antarctica
would it be the case that there will be
fewer species if there was only a thin
strand of regions on the earth which
could support any kind of life by virtue
of the chemistry would there be fewer
species i don't think we know the answer
to that interesting question
um
there's a question is it five crossovers
out of i believe sorry but i certainly
my children are nothing nothing they may
be they may be special and wonderful
people but they're they're not special
with respect to genomics and i think my
um
um
uh
you know i i was very pleased when i got
my genome sequence so a dozen years ago
now um i was sort of pleased to discover
that my
um
my genome is in many ways very typical
of human genomes and didn't seem to have
too many bizarre sort of variations
which is probably good news because sort
of uh natural selection on our species
has meant that the sort of the average
genome is kind of a genome that's going
to do okay as opposed to a genome that
has a very weird feature here
that um uh you know could be really good
but could also be really bad
um i think
the there is a question you know when
you look at
the human genome people say we've
sequenced the human genome there is a
question of which genome because there
are seven billion humans on the earth
and they all have different genomes and
people are asking what's the how big is
the variation
um
the i i i i unfortunately i don't know
somebody can look that up i i don't know
the immediate answer i know that the the
number of of uh individual variation is
about seven hundred thousand uh snips
seven hundred thousand individual um
individual positions on the genome but
i've forgotten what it is for for
typically between two individuals um uh
how many how many differences there are
that aren't individually different from
everybody else so to speak
but um
uh uh yeah
so
there's a question um
here from journey are memes on the
internet conceptually a species
well yes i think so i mean i think that
what does it mean
when there's a very interesting question
actually i mean
natural selection
the idea that
there is a
a thing
that when you have a thing that we have
many variations of a thing
and
certain success criteria for that thing
cause there to be more copies of the
thing
that is the basic process of natural
selection and it applies to many
different kinds of things it might apply
to products in produced by companies it
might apply to planets in a solar system
that are you know knocked out of the
solar system or not
and potentially it applies to memes on
the internet
and there's sort of a i think the memes
on the internet case is perhaps
a um
yeah i mean this question of whether see
one thing that doesn't tend to happen
with biological species is the merging
of species that is once you've got is
really a tree of life two species at
least for higher organisms if not for
viruses um you know when you get uh you
know two when you speciate when you make
a horse versus a versus a donkey versus
a zebra those are really separate
branches
and you know unless they can mate and if
you assume they can't because they broke
into separate species by that definition
of species they're a tree they're
separated
now i suspect when it comes to memes on
the internet there could be ones
there could be a different process which
is a process of merging that happens for
example with words and languages you can
have words where
a single word kind of breaks into
um
two different um
two different words but you can also
have perhaps rarer processes where two
different words end up being you know
coming together to be the same word
jonas asks so is a species just
determined by
by visual features or by breeding this
is this is one of the big questions of
systematic biology
is um uh you know when you look at um
uh to what extent
can you identify species by morphology
by the form of the organism
versus to what extent is the dna the the
sort of the the right thing
well actually
okay there are three different
definitions you could use one is can the
organisms breed with each other the
other another is do the organisms look
the same
and the final one is do the organisms um
do they how different is their dna so
take dog breeds as an example dog breeds
are a messy case because dog breeds can
to some extent mate with each other but
yet dog breeds can be visually
morphologically seem really quite
different
um their dna i'm not sure how different
their dna is not sure about that um and
to what extent you can identify these i
mean you certainly can identify dog
breeds by their dna just as you can
identify
things with um uh with different um um
the um
uh
with different um
um
uh
that you can identify you know humans
who come from different parts of the
world and so on
um
and uh
the
um
um
well let's see i think i i'm going to
need to go in a moment and actually i'm
going to be doing another live stream
about a much more technical topic
but um
uh
let's see
well just maybe one more comment on um
oh yeah i was talking about the
different difference between the
morphological definition of species just
by the form of things versus the dna
version
um i know
one time
silly personal story oh i know 15 years
ago 10 years ago something like that
there was some some kind of
uh
bug beetle type thing um and it was like
at a house and it was like is this a bed
bug is this a you know is this a is this
some kind of um you know is it a
terrible infestation of this kind of
thing and so it's like well is it or
isn't it we have the specimen and it's
like can we identify this this critter
and so i look it up on the web and i
also people have been using actually our
technology to try and make beetle
identification
um
where which are these days when we do
with machine learning and vision systems
but then it was more kind of how many
legs does it well they all have the same
number of legs how many antennae does it
have you know how
ramified it's antennae things like this
i look at this stuff and it's like i
cannot tell no idea because it's just
too difficult to follow all these you
know that they're usually these species
identification
uh kind of flow charts and you can do
that you know there are there are these
things like leaf identification flow
charts we say does the leaf have this
shape or that shape if it if it is a if
it is a simple leaf you know one blob of
leaf then it's this but it's a compound
leaf in many pieces you go down this
branch if it's a serrated leaf where it
has a serrated edge you know a kind of a
wiggly edge versus say a straight edge
then
then you go to this branch and so on and
eventually you're going down all these
branches and eventually say okay that
must be an oak tree well there's similar
kinds of things for beetles it's just
more complicated because i think there
are more kinds of beetles than there are
for example flowering plants
um and so i ended up um taking this
specimen into um uh
people i knew who were in entomology
department at a at a natural history
museum
and saying can we identify this beetle
and it's like well yes sure we can
identify this and they start pulling out
these drawers of beetles and it's like
zillions and zillions of beetles all
looking slightly morphologically
different and eventually it was possible
to say yes this beetle i have in my hand
it looks like that one and none of the
others in other words there really is a
morphological difference um but that's a
complicated thing and in the world of
taxonomy where you're trying to decide
what things should be called and
particularly you're trying to decide
what's most related to what what is in
the same family as what what should be
considered because one has this whole
you know families and and uh orders and
phyla
and this whole sort of hierarchy of of
description and the tree of life and
there are often vigorous arguments
about
whether something should be considered
in the same family as this or not and
and actually when we've tried to curate
the taxonomic tree for wolf and alpha
for example uh we find we run into all
kinds of difficulties because there's
one group of taxonomists that says no no
this type of bird should be grouped with
that type of bird and another says no no
that's absolutely wrong you should group
it with this other type of bird there's
there's quite a
vigorous um kind of
set of discussions about those kinds of
things based on morphology now if you
went to look at the dna of those things
you said how different is the dna you
will again get some tree of differences
because you know this dna is different
from that dna and then it's similar to
that dna you can group things together
in some kind of tree but it's an
inferred tree because all you have is
those pieces of dna you don't have the
complete history of how did this
organism you don't have the complete
history of organisms that lead you to
know this particular set of branches go
to this particular set of organisms and
so on
so in any case that that's a
this question about sort of is there a
global theory of kind of how speciation
happens
how
how one should think about this kind of
uh set of you know the the for example
how one should think about the existence
of different organisms the different
numbers of numbers of individuals of
different organisms all these kinds of
things there isn't a good global theory
of these things there are there are
pieces in evolutionary biology there are
particular situations in which you can
use things like game theory to try to
figure out
certain kinds of outcomes where you can
say this combination of of things will
combine this way and the result of that
is you'll have twice as many of this
organism in that organism or twice as
many of this gender of this organism and
that gender of that organism and so on
um but there are comparatively few cases
where it's possible to see just by
virtue of kind of the the um the
competition the local competition
between species for example um where you
can see that type of thing
and the global question of like why are
there
let's say 10 million four to ten million
species in the world it's just not known
and you know to have a global theory of
that and to have something which allows
you to tell that will be very
interesting i mean for example we don't
know
if in the pre-cambrian period um or
where we we just have a few
you know little pieces of fossils from
that time we don't know maybe there were
a trillion species in those days maybe
before life had worked itself out it's
to the extent that it has now maybe
there were vastly more kinds of
organisms maybe
maybe life was trying out a lot more
possibilities and it kind of whittled
itself down to the number we have today
um it's um
i think uh uh that that's some
uh and over the course of you know the
fossil record we know you know the
number of species that we find in
fossils has gone up and down as there
are big extinctions where you know 80
percent of the species will go extinct
and stuff like this but the total number
of species in the in the main part of
the fossil record hasn't apparently at
least the ones that we find as fossils
doesn't seem to have changed that much
um but in earlier periods of life it
might have been very different i think
um
it's uh
um oh okay there's one last question
from jonas here and i should wrap up but
can genetic traits lay dormant for
centuries or millennia
recurring changes after after some
number of generations that's an
interesting question
so
it reminds me there's a science fiction
movie where
the the um uh
it's called something rising i've
forgotten what it's called but it's uh
where the where the kind of concept is
that there's a a chain of succession of
you know who's in charge of the galaxy
and that chain of succession is whenever
the exact same genome shows up again
then just by random mutations then that
person will be in charge of the galaxy
or whatever the truth is that would take
a ridiculously long time far for any
organism with genome size comparable to
the kinds of ones that we have that will
be an absurdly you know vastly
unbelievably longer than the lifetime of
the universe i suppose one could pick a
small piece of the genome actually it's
a good question i mean for the
mitochondrion for example our the energy
source in our cells that's kind of been
evolved separately from the rest of us
and passes down the female line in in
organisms like us
the mitochondrion is
1600 base pairs maybe something like
that
is that right i'm not sure um so the
question would be
have
of the 100 billion humans that have ever
lived have
has
how many times has the mitochondrion by
pure chance
been a repeated mitochondrion exactly
repeated mitochondrion now of course it
isn't the case that every base pair in
the mitochondrion is picked at random um
so i'm not quite sure what the answer to
that would be but that's an interesting
question how often do things just by
pure chance
end up being exactly the same now
there's a question could there be a
trait
yes the answer okay so the issue is in
our genetic
in our genome there are all kinds of
crazy pieces of the genome that were
genes that were
produced proteins that were super useful
when those genes first existed in a fish
or something for us
well
most of the time we don't activate that
gene
probably there is some pruning process
that gets rid of the junk at some rate
but probably not that higher rate
because it isn't that expensive to carry
along extra pieces of genome
um as for an organism and so the
question would be are there
are there for example pieces of our
genome
that
are have been unused for a long time but
suddenly
for example when we colonize mars
suddenly the folks who colonize mars
there'll be genes that start getting uh
transcribed from genomes of of mars
colonists that have never been used by
by any humans on earth for example could
that happen could there be pieces and
the answer is sure there are parts of
our genome that are
that
we make use of i don't know when we're
dealing with i don't know
parasite infections that are not so
common in the kind of you know in the
sort of ultra clean
western world or something as they are
in other parts of the world um you know
we just don't activate those parts of
our our genetic makeup now the question
is could there be something where
there's kind of a
a
a very recessive trait something which
which uh yeah
okay so so often you know because we
have two copies of every chromosome
there are certain traits like eye color
where you know you can have a dominant
trait as soon as you have one brown eye
as soon as either of your
um either of the chromosomes that
contain the eye color gene as soon as
either of them is a brown gene your eye
color will be brown basically because
you're making a protein you make at
least some of a protein and that protein
makes the eye brown
and so you end up with blue eyes you
only get blue eyes if both your
chromosomes
have um
uh have um uh that carry that gene have
um
the um uh have
don't have the one for making the brown
eye uh protein so a question would be
is there
a way in which one can have
um
genes that's an interesting question
could you have a chain of genes
that is not just dominant recessive
um but is something where you have to
have a whole sequence of genes
be a particular way for it to be the
case that some other gene is activated i
think the answer is definitely yes i
don't know of a specific example but i
think that that could be a yes that only
when certain a certain collection of of
of uh of genes sort of line up for
example between
um between the the different chromosomes
and so on then you could end up having
some trait that would otherwise have
been a lost trait i'm sure because in
genetics there's usually an example of
everything i'm sure there's an example
of that um i just don't know what it is
offhand
all right i should uh i should wrap up
here and um going to be doing another
live stream about a much more technical
topic about molecular computing um
that's just a working session
um and uh i should uh
wrap up so
uh
thanks for joining us a lot of good
questions today
and um
uh we'll cover
some of the ones we didn't get to today
i'll hopefully cover next time and
please think of great questions and i
think you can probably send them in
somewhere um and they'll get stored up
so we can make use of them in a
subsequent one of these
so thanks for joining us
see